so the finale of Loki season 2 happened
last night and it was amazing I would
argue it was the greatest ending to a
Marvel Cinematic Universe project and
the entire history of the MCU and it
makes me very excited about what happens
next except for Captain America New
World Order apparently it's going
through a whole bunch of re-shoot
because people hated it when they saw it
so the big question everybody's asking
here is what happened like what's going
on the last 15 minutes just kind of left
people baffled okay so here's the thing
right as soon as he grabbed the
universes he started walking and he sat
down in the chair I immediately knew
what happened I immediately knew and I
was there was I was like there was no
way they made him that guy but sure
enough they did right so here was the
thing Loki was set with an impossible
task right like after getting control of
his time slipping Loki started going
back in time different points along the
timeline trying to figure out a way to
keep the destruction of the Loom from
happening but then he realized there was
no conceivable way of stopping it so so
long as he who remains died the
inevitable logical conclusion was that
the loom would eventually be destroyed
and everything in existence would
basically unravel right except for quote
unquote the sacred timeline right but
any other Universe would basically cease
to exist and seemingly all of creation
would cease to exist as we saw basically
everything unraveling everywhere so in
turn Loki had to accept the fact that in
order to ensure the continued existence
of creation itself that he who remains
would have to survive but in order to
keep him alive he would have to kill
Sylvie and that's when he came to the
realization what if there's a third
option here right one that hadn't been
considered what if I destroy the loom
and replace it with something better so
Loki does that right like he goes back
to being the original Loki with just the
baller looking outfit and the most
dramatic moment ever destroys the loom
and then as Sylvie points out all the
universes are dying right they're
literally just ceasing to exist so Loki
seizes control of the universes walks up
to what was the Throne of he who remains
sits on it anchors the universes to
himself and basically restores them all
Loki recreates the Multiverse here's the
kicker to this right rumors abound a lot
of people out there speculating on what
Loki has now become the most popular
Theory out there is that Loki is now the
god of stories that's not true if Loki
were the god of stories he would just
rewrite the entirety of the m ver the
reason being that as the god of stories
that's his power right in Marvel Comics
right now Loki has the ability to
basically write anything he wants to and
it becomes true so if Loki in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe had now become the
god of stories he would have just
Rewritten the entire history of the
Multiverse and like that would be it
there never would have been a he who
remains there never would have been a
war of the Kings it would have just
brought an end to the Multiverse Saga
over the span of 15 minutes right so
that's not the case there are people who
were saying that he is the one above all
you could certainly make an argument
there but there's no reason to believe
that's true because all Loki has done
was brought the Multiverse back that's
all he did here right he didn't create
the Multiverse right it's not as though
all the things that existed blinked out
of existence and Loki has now recreated
everything including Sylvie Obie Mobius
and everybody who was there within the
time variant Authority so he's certainly
not the one above all he's definitely
not the fulcrum who's an aspect of the
one above all he's not the Living
Tribunal the person that Loki is now
playing in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
is somebody you would only be aware of
if you had read the one comic book that
they appeared in which was called
Infinity Abyss written by a guy named
Jim Sterling Loki is now playing the
role of ATL the custodian of the
Multiverse what does that mean so in
Marvel Comics the entirety of the
Multiverse has a whole host of different
concepts to it some of which are very
wellknown eternity Infinity The Living
Tribunal galatis so on and so forth some
of them are incredibly obscure
anthropomor right like whenever Cosmic
entities appear in a physical form is
because they go to a realm called the
dimension of manifestations anthropomor
gives them what's called an embody I.E a
physical form they can literally put
their Essence in and then they appear in
their own particular Universe to whoever
it is they're supposed to be talking to
this even applies to The Living Tribunal
right everybody shy of the one above all
uses embodies from anthropomor but
another really obscure character is the
custodian of the Multiverse in Infinity
Abyss which was really just kind of Jim
Starin writing his own stories that
existed out there within the Multiverse
of Marvel Comics at Les was introduced
to us as a guy that anchors the
Multiverse what did Loki do he literally
anchored the Multiverse to himself to
his Essence to his very being it's tied
directly to him it was his power that
restored the Multiverse and so the whole
role that Atlas plays is to quote
unquote keep the Multiverse from sinking
into Oblivion no it's not a direct
reference to the cosmic entity Oblivion
but basically the way it works is that
by whatever Manner and whatever means a
universe will come into existence
sometimes it branches off the main
Marvel Universe sometimes it's always
just been there but whatever the reason
is it has its beginning date and it has
its end date leaving out Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers the
collapse of the Multiverse The
incursions Secret Wars 2015 and all that
kind of stuff the Multiverse has a
beginning and an end every Universe has
a beginning and an end the role that
Atlas plays is to keep those different
universes from sinking into Oblivion
thus reaching their premature end
everything all of creation is anchored
explicitly through him and much like
what you saw in Loki where he's sitting
on the throne that previously belonged
to he who remains it Bears a striking
resemblance to the throne of Atlas right
he just sits in this chair and the
Multiverse anchors through him and
that's it when Atlas died Adam Warlock
and gamor grabbed a young girl named at
leza and she became the new custodian of
the Multiverse a custodian always has to
exist there now within the MCU You could
argue that the name he who remains is
interchangeable with the custodian and
in fact you could go so far as to say
that Loki is quote unquote the new he
who remains but if what you're looking
for is a onetoone comparison a character
in Marvel Comics that occupies and plays
the same role that Loki is playing in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe right now
it's Atlas he's really cool incredibly
powerful this guy can do all kinds of
wild stuff now the real question that
has to be asked here is will there come
a time when Loki will leave his role as
custodian of the Multiverse and either
return to the main marel Universe per se
they'll kill him off I don't
definitively know truth to tell if I'm
being honest with you and a buddy of
mine Alex kind of feels the same way and
I feel like this is the prevailing
theory that exists out there that Loki
is going to come to the realization that
in order for the Kings to be defeated a
multiversal Avengers team is going to
have to be created and he's going to
quote unquote vacate his throne and then
he's in turn going to go and form a
multiversal Avengers team the
alternative is he will bring those
individuals to him and he will say you
are now the multiversal Avengers here's
everything that's going on you guys now
have to go deal with him right as far as
we're aware the TVA has no direct
contact with Loki so again I'm really
kind of excited to see what happens
after this let me know what you guys
think is going to happen to Loki down in
the comments I want to know your
thoughts do you think this is Marvel
just writing him out of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe we'll never see him
again after this do you think he's going
to return and then ultimately they'll
kill him off let me know what your
thoughts are but with that being said
guys we're going to bring this to an end
and I will catch you all later peace